fue un hombre de cambios y se convirtió
en una figura icónica del siglo 20
nacido en 1931 en una familia campesina
mijail gorbachov estuvo en la cima de la
unión soviética y desde ahí presenció su
caída
para decirlo brevemente la caída del
muro de berlín fue una señal de lo que
estaba pasando en el mundo y hacia dónde
se dirigía su multa ríolobos
y útil este acontecimiento dio lugar a
una gran cantidad de cambios
gorbachov de igual poder en 1985 a la
edad de 54 años y representó una nueva
era para el partido comunista su
objetivo salvar el sistema soviético
mediante reformas y los cambios no se
limitaron a los asuntos internos con la
intención de calentar las relaciones de
la guerra fría con eeuu gorbachov inició
un diálogo pionero que acabó firmando un
tratado bilateral para reducir las armas
nucleares en 1988 retiró las tropas
rusas de afganistán
gorbachov trató de poner en marcha una
economía estancada mediante una
combinación de reestructuración y
transparencia gubernamental
conocida como glasnost y perestroika
pero los problemas financieros del país
se empeoraron los liberales le acusaron
de ser demasiado lento y los
conservadores de llevar al país a la
ruina los coreanos
por supuesto que hemos cometido errores
hemos esperado demasiado tiempo para
reformar el partido comunista para
reformar también la unión soviética no
previmos los problemas que se avecinaban
cuando la gente empezó a ganar más ya
consumir más
el mercado no estaba en absoluto
abastecido para satisfacer la demanda de
ahí las enormes colas en las tiendas
en agosto de 1991 gorbachov sobrevivió a
un intento de golpe de estado pero el
daño estaba hecho bajo la presión del
nuevo presidente ruso borís yeltsin y de
otros estados
límite como presidente de la urss la
unión soviética había caído
cuando vi el acuerdo que se había
firmado para crear una nueva comunidad
de estados salí en la televisión y
declaré que cesaría mis actividades como
presidente no estaba obligado a hacerlo
escuchar state
podía haber convocado al congreso de los
diputados del pueblo el soviet supremo
también podría haber llamado al ejército
pero vi que lo que estaba ocurriendo era
irreversible que el pueblo estaría
dividido aunque hubiera votado en marzo
por la conservación de la unión
soviética pero no quería ningún
derramamiento de sangre así que no tome
estas medidas o visiones
su mayor de arrepentimiento la caída de
la unión soviética su reputación al
interior nunca se recuperó tras el
colapso pero le hizo ganarse el cariño
de algunas naciones ex soviéticas y de
occidente su papel en el fin de la
guerra fría también le valió el premio
nobel de la paz